spektakuläre bilder supernovaexplosion
zum ersten mal aufgezeichnet jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction forschern der
university of notre dame im us
bundesstaat indiana ist es erstmals
gelungen einen schock breakout einer
supernova im sichtbaren licht
aufzuzeichnen die supernova sn 2011 d
ist ungefähr 1,2 milliarden lichtjahre
von uns entfernt und war vorher ein
roter riese der stern der im zuge der
supernova sn 2011 d explodiert ist hatte
einen durchmesser der dem 500 fachen
durchmesser unserer sonne entspricht der
gesamte kollaps des riesen dauerte rund
20 minuten bei der supernova handelte
sich um eine typ 2 supernova dabei wurde
der gesamte wasserstoff des sterns zu
helium umgewandelt im inneren bildet
sich ein fester kern die kernfusion wird
durch ihn gestoppt und der stern
kollabiert das äußere material des
sterns sturz mit 70.000 kilometern pro
sekunde auf den festen kern und wird
zurückgeschlagen eine aufnahme davon war
bisher noch niemandem gelungen jetzt
ermöglichte den wissenschaftlern das
kepler weltraumteleskop diesen schock
breakout erstmals aufzuzeichnen das ist
das teleskop das in erster linie auf der
suche nach exoplaneten ist und einem
schock breakout verstehen die experten
den bis zu 30.000 kilometer pro sekunde
schnellen durchbruch der stoßwelle bei
der explosion in den 20 minuten in denen
der rote riese kollabierte konnten die
forscher die druckwelle durch das kepler
teleskop beobachten indem die gesamte
helligkeit der galaxie betrachtet wurde
die supernova führte zu einer erhöhung
für eine kurze zeit heller als alle
anderen lichtquellen nach rund 20
minuten brach die druckwelle komplett
durch und wandelte sich in
sekundenschnelle in eine heiße gaswolken
in diesen wenigen sekunden sieht man
einfach nur einen hellen blitz oder wie
nasa in ihrer meldung verkündete court
for the first time i saw the exploding
star ohne supernovae werden wir übrigens
eigentlich gar nicht da nur durch
supernovae gibt es so vielfältige
materialien in unserem sonnensystem
alles was schwerer als das element eisen
ist stammt aus einem stern kollaps zum
ersten mal entdeckt menschen eine
supernova übrigens im jahr 185 sie wurde
von chinesischen astronomen
beachtet die song dynastie konnte am
vierten juli 1054 eine weitere supernova
und deren überreste den sogenannten
krebsnebel beobachten dieser war damals
fast einen monat lang so hell dass man
ihn am tage von der erde aus sehen
konnte im november 572 robra den
supernovae ihren namen eine beobachtung
am sternenhimmel nannte er nova da er
das helle leuchten für einen neuen stern
hielt die das ist ein neuer stern
vermutung hat noch einige andere
wissenschaftler am 9 oktober 604 wurden
lario altobelli raffaello gold therapie
und am 17 oktober 16 4 auch johannes
kepler zeuge einer der letzten
supernovae in unserer milchstraße
die supernova sn 16 04 hielt auch
keppler zuerst für einen neuen stern
die italienischen kollegen konnten ihn
aber dann eines besseren belehren
nichtsdestotrotz ist es in 16 04 besser
unter dem namen keplers stern bekannt
die jetzige beobachtung in der 1,2
milliarden lichtjahre entfernten galaxie
dieser court for the first time the
early flashen exploding star ist wichtig
für die wissenschaftler im fachmagazin
nature erklärt wird die forscher dort
berichten trete eine supernova in der
milchstraße nur zwei mal in 100 jahren
auf die gelegenheit mehr über supernovae
herauszufinden ist also relativ gering
eine aetna supernova wäre auch nicht
unbedingt wünschenswert davon spricht
man wenn das ereignis in unter 100
lichtjahren entfernung von uns passiert
bei entfernung von 26 löchern könnte es
schon gefährlich werden die erde würde
dann einer hohen gamma strahlung
ausgesetzt werden die ozonschicht würde
zerstört und damit könnte sehr viel
schädliche strahlungen die
planetenoberfläche erreichen und es
könnte ein massensterben geben die
wissenschaft die zeit 1993 davon aus
dass die nächsten a supernova durch den
doppelstern ik pegasi zustande kommen
wird und der ist gott sei dank 150
lichtjahre von uns entfernt und von
seinem zustand her noch weit von einer
supernova entfernt außerdem entfernt er
sich alle 14.700 jahre um ein lichtjahr
von unserer sonne
die wird übrigens als gelber zwerg
bezeichnen wie ihren 4 6 milliarden
jahren hat sie noch nicht mal die hälfte
der zeit bis zu ihrem ende hinter sich
gebracht
insgesamt so haben wissenschaftler
berechnet werden 11,7 milliarden jahre
vergehen bis die sonne zu einem roten
riesen und sich damit um das 10.000
fache vergrößern wird an diesem punkt
erreicht die sonne auch die erde wird
diese natürlich vernichten durch den
ausstoß von masse
wird die sonne von einem roten riesen zu
einem weißen zwerg etwa in der größe der
erde
die weitere entwicklung ist rein
hypothetisch forscher gehen davon aus
dass diesem zustand der schwarz werk
folgen wird dann strahlt die sonne keine
energie mehr aus und ist im sichtbaren
bereich nicht mehr erkennbar
allerdings ist das weltall erst 13 7
milliarden als also zu jung um einen
schwarzen zwerg hervorgebracht zu haben
so die meinung der wissenschaft aus der
sonne wird also keine supernova
hervorgehen dafür ist ihre masse zu
gering wenn euch das video gefallen hat
dann würde ich mich natürlich über einen
daumen nach oben freuen
vergesst nicht ein kostenloses abo dazu
lassen und was würdet ihr denn gerne
über supernovae oder vielleicht auch
andere vorgänge im all wissen welche
fragen würde die astronomen stellen
schreibt sie uns in die kommentare und
wir könnten ja vielleicht in den
nächsten videos darauf eingehen mit
einem fragt sie kam mal wieder ja also
seid gespannt bislang bleibt dran